[Applause]
tgif i'm going
casual friday oh yeah
oh you guys it's so nice to see all our
vffs
and by the way hi everybody your signs
are always so amazing and it just means
the world to us that you are here
and i will be your bff anytime
i'm here right now and it's funny
because i
woke up this morning i looked around and
i always am worried my alarm is gonna
wake up my two daughters because they
were sleeping with me
and i my alarm went off and i looked
around and
i had my two daughters and then our cat
lucky our cat peach lucy
and douglas and there was just it looked
like we were sleeping in noah's ark and
it was the most
cozy beautiful moment
and i just i felt so lucky
my first kids really were my animals
and now i have kids so you know the pets
come
second but they're family and i just
i love getting to be with my daughters
and the
and our pets so when i heard about all
the work
of one of our vfs today kelly donnelly
was doing to make sure that families and
their pets stayed together
during the pandemic i really wanted to
meet her
so kelly are you there yes
hi kelly how are you
[Applause]
excuse me speaking of pets i have a frog
in my throat
oh my gosh i do too because i'm just so
excited to meet you
thank you oh i'm so glad you're here
and when i heard your story i just
thought
okay i wanted to tell the story of my
morning because
our pets are so important to us
and you started a food pantry for pets
out of your garage so that people could
take care of their animals
i mean what gave you the idea to do that
yeah
so i've been a rescuer for a long time a
solid rescuer since 2012 i love
animals and i know that that's always an
issue
um needing pet food and needing care and
so with the pandemic
i just knew things were that much worse
i was hearing so many stories of
individuals having to surrender their
pets due to not being able to feed them
and you know that's heart-wrenching
they're like our children right you know
you just talked about all your babies in
your bed with you and your kids
and that's heartbreaking i feel like
during such trying times that's the last
thing that a family needs is to have to
surrender their pet um so i just decided
to take to facebook
and see if there was any way that i
could help um local families in need
and what responses did you get oh my
gosh
drew it was so crazy on both sides of
the coin
there were so many so many individuals
that wanted to help i couldn't believe
how many folks were offering to send and
bring food and then on top of that i
actually set some days where i would
actually go out into the community
and help folks who didn't have
transportation who couldn't come pick up
the food
and drew that was actually the hardest
part for me because
when i put out a post um asking you know
hey if you aren't able to get to me but
i can deliver
i got some of the saddest stories you
know i would end up in places that
that you could really tell that the need
was
yeah i mean kelly we want to continue to
help you spread the love so
we reached out to our friends at petco
and i'm such a petco fan
so because of you they want to give you
five thousand dollars
for vet bills and
another five thousand dollars for pet
food
yes thank you
thank you so much i can't even begin to
tell you the vet bills too
that's something else we've been trying
so hard to work on that is so
huge well you inspired us to think
differently
and the fact that you are thinking
differently is just such a great benefit
thank you guys creatures on four and two
legs and so
thank you for all that you are doing
kelly thank you for letting us celebrate
you
so awesome thank you i can't wait to see
you do more and we'll keep in touch
and see how it's all going thank you
you